jim literally wrong
value out of our work
let me know
bologna and along
she's back home i mean
mylife competing you have to go to work
in on the left you never came back and
about a month later they tell me that
there were three corpses enunciation on
friday and plenty of beheaded community
in stripped him naked
my brothers
to disappeared into the murder of a
local while at all
notify plainfield
he look like it
territorial albania
baha i don't know
yea mammals
this is all done to try to find
themselves
so we gather strength and forward
it is a power struggle and they will not
silence s
we will continue to speak out in the in
our country in around the world against
what is happening here in el salvador
came up and pay
but i didn't get it
pomona ca nine valued and that the land
a
the
most people in a little bit of rain
starting with lost farmers content this
e-mail some
we think there are a student entrance
over the past century
salvador's wealthier families have taken
nearly all the best farmland from the
campus seniors
is welcoming engineers use their
plantations to grow condi cochran and
sugar came for export
nikon has denounced condemned for us to
move to the cities
because clinton show images are minimal
and job sixteen oklahoma city are also
scarce
dalaberti or something to go about
alcohol carried unemployed carpenter and
try it
maneuverable whose real name
the people of el salvador live amidst
misery and death
anywhere you walk in the city you see it
with people in misery here
one could say all but there's lots of
commerce here
people selling things on the street
this is totally false people are
outselling on the streets so as not to
die of hunger in the view of the room
with you
even tho i think they had then let me
see note haney on miami
and and i'm going to happen when you
this is the result of the malnutrition
latest and most of the children in these
communities in india
for lack of food and drug reminding
domain noticed so expensive that it is
hard to find a
the children are dying of malnutrition
any no-one my second son themselves with
the survival of these children only end
up at the time and that it did not get a
feeling
four five billion in buffalo in nine
ninety
don't think they did before it gets done
yesterday evening
if you want the families who are most of
the land
makeup and oligarchy
which controls the politics in el
salvador along with the armed forces
many social movements have grown up in
response to this clearing inequality
over the past ten years
hundreds of thousands of people have
participating groups working for
democracy and greater equality
kingston's have included campus
denounced
students professionals the catholic
church
and having the
fairly common finances you know
colonies tend
the roots of the labor movements in this
country have are found in the hunger in
the misery in which we live informal
we're struggling to improve our lives so
that our children can survive and have
the opportunities but only if you have
had
clinton along for the premiere of
kaylynn thomas-samuel
here
gaya including the putting them in the
armed forces
tragic crash the new political movement
one of those dealt with the roman
catholic archbishop discoverable ramiro
between nineteen seventy nine a m
actually door
overflowing in two thousand alarms
volpert dot the military
the issue
if they're going to run with you
in nineteen eighty billion freshen
against my family beginning
on december twentieth nineteen eighty
they murdered my oldest brother even if
he were to michigan refinery and belong
to the union there
any repression against my family
continue
twenty twenty seven members of my family
had been killed
bien
would be available
we want to go to learn
in nineteen eighty four i was captured
visitor has captured for being a
representative of the workers and the
union members isn't it was interrogated
and tortured psychologically as well as
physically
receptive to it that way
conveyancing oregon
it was only a minor role in the mail and
then
let alone
the april eighteen thousand looked
forward and you don't eat broccoli
anybody
poor and no binding nature of the things
i didn't hear any u_s_ because i had to
leave el salvador that because there was
a union member i was captured by the
army and held in jail for two-and-a-half
years
when i was in jail my mother was
murdered
and so you can see through the
regression pain only split up families
and but they kill people within families
as well
he didn't come
armed resistance under the banner
alright
paramecium dash corporation
grumman strength in the countryside
military concludes commanders of a
nonprofit
katrina and continued throughout the
nineteen people
don't clearly mentioning commensurate
steady flow of money to help stop the
dark
committed to look for the reagan
administration helped connect with a
different direction
avenue salvadoran president
calls dot
and okay
lonelier also made quickly and then they
don't but the infield along with it bob
i can sympathize with the president to
make speeches about peace
at the same time is sending his
ministers to the u_s_ to seek a new
sophisticated weapons helicopters
airplanes more bullets
bullets don't bring us beans are rice it
produced destruction and death
luther lift them feeling
rules and will not be the from nineteen
of the endorses carried out of the tenth
bombing in the countryside hundreds of
thousands aquino's have been forced to
flee their homes
into any of the immediate
eighty eight we had to watch
eighty-fifth teeny days and nights
sometimes up to minors three thousand to
four thousand people gleaned from the
military
would force us to leave their places of
origin instead pitiful catalytically
people have fled cities
and to refugee camps warehousing and
sanitation are poor
it desktop p_c_ honestly cannot make a
life city
but we don't have a place to hide we
call me to is commission making we can't
use is here
if you hear you say making out like a
lot more cynical and bogosian then we
can do that you don't mind telling
teachers union
the people of el salvador in growing
numbers and joining together to bring
about change
one movement for change has gone on too
much of the females
who want to go back to the conventions
didn't copy me population movements
it grew out of people's desperation to
escape the living conditions in the city
in refugee camps
erratically kick the capital city san
salvador
in october of nineteen eighty six
elderly population and that was
developing
invest an estimated two hundred thousand
people homeless including many of the
people who had moved from the
countryside
the well deck
most of the earthquake victims are
displaced families
first displaced by the war
and now that you're explaining
this situation is worsening and now he's
displaced people are getting involved in
my article is a struggle to return to
their places abortion it
for
military tries to harding diligent
the families making temperatures
military often tries to keep them from
st
repopulate villages had been bombed
sometimes pipe government troops
intimidated people u_s_a_ airline can
you tell people that worry goes out and
smile groups from house to house to talk
with the people why did you go back to
him tomorrow
daylight is much easier to stay
and the how my family stable seriously
know that my there you have to buy
everything elected word fruitful
where we find work funny how can we
support our children insult paralyzed
our interview alleges gets here i'll
anecdote so we want to cultivate we
support our children to our own entrance
and no longer if they like parasites in
a refugee camp
cope without these do you
status
and can if they want to kill us camp you
have to have talents
but we will not lieutenant dot paavam
acting like that when we are petals
ultra liberal label
banking info war
consider that since nineteen seventy
nine more than sixty two thousand people
have been killed here in el salvador and
more than seven thousand have
disappeared also in the united states
there are nearly a million salvadoran
refugees with both
in response to the killings and
disappearances
organizations of point to demands that
the government stopped the repression
one of these organizations as context
a group of mothers and alex is the
people who have been murdered
kidnapped
who had officially disappeared
one prominent example of their work
within a half nineteen eighty-seven
critical madras immediately came to the
support three mothers whose sons had
been captured
evaporated butterfield
recapture employees was on may first
nineteen eighty seven after workers
demonstration
affair to miami and i would
handles these three matters excessive
every legal recourse in trying to locate
their sons
i an indiana limit with desolate
planning on this issue
anything you might not know no way that
the other
actually came which have not knowing the
whereabouts next time
but knowing who had them the armed
forces
we did three mothers decided to go on a
hunger strike
with the support of come mondays we went
to the cathedral to start the hunger
strike
on that same saturday we were beaten by
a troop at sixty please
they wanted to get us out at the
cathedral ph hughes says that being a
part of the f_m_l_n_ strategy
because we're on a hunger strike
demanding freedom of our son
in a way that it may be the end of it
mediate if although there are witnesses
to the captures that these science
the army and the government have not
been able to help or even respond
non field up my faith in atlanta
explained
from another look at the annual
damien
until they have clarified what has
happened to be disappear he and release
the political prisoners and into the
justices practice does have assassinated
our relatives we won't start marching in
the streets non-union funny and
haha
hat
playgroup unions have weather during the
past few years campaign that encourages
important conditions have worsened
oh
financial happiest in my people
struggling struggle is far depart
aa
we've been on strike for fifty one days
management has responded with threats
and harassment
david
email
thousand workers have been fired
when we want to assemble to police
intervened and as a result of that there
have been regressive confrontations
between police and the workers
itself or at the moment there
being whipped up by
unfortunately in our country most
strikes declared you legalize it create
text for taking repressive actions
against union leaders
product of my profanity s
corn that would be hinted that looked
awesome
demos
we want to explain that the workers'
demands are labor or you can
and the government's replies are always
military and violent
uh... maybe union
the inflatable humvees union leaders are
struggle is not only for those in our
workplace
but a struggle of an entire nation
against the suffering of our people
because the injustices of the government
and the oligarchy our country
into the movie
these young
may have been doing
migration
lenoir demand has grown stronger
february of nineteen eighty six
trade unions agricultural workers and
students religious groups
state workers and human rights groups
home came together under one
organization
cocking lever pins
the national union salvadoran workers
one of the internet and independent
european settlement and warm
but would you would agree with that
create the military to the u_n_ g_s_ was
the most important event in nineteen
eighty six in el salvador
for the first time in history are common
misery brought us together
workers farm cooperative members
indigenous people come to see knows
state workers
the knowing that they think
north i do though
are quoted on the saturn
i think the u_n_ t_s_ helped us to
organize ourselves to mad as hell we
formed an organization to represent the
interests of the earthquake victims
assistant that
no speed data access
they're not done if you go
internal in india it
been in the area
it there are new groups drawing the u_n_
t_s_ all the time
do we have organized several
demonstrations to show that we are
determined to fight for our goals
but on the uh... them with uh... that
he's done with them
the legacy of
reverse the order if the reader
databases
does indicate that they were just going
to repress generic retreated
we know who their struggle is just and
it gives us the strength to move forward
demanding their rights you can if it
involves risking our lives
so that our children will have a better
future
them obviously that was
not only have a house whose vote it was
determined that there be a that they
have a problem in the one that was the
one or more often
remover
logo
the cost does not matter we either
workers will continue our struggle
there are two options we either die of
hunger or we fight and we're going to
fight
bladder
el salvador is now a different largest
recipient of usd in the world
and i'm not going to be in the don't
mean you lived in the n_b_a_
for baghdad now i'll salvador e_c_'s two
million dollars per day from the united
states government
his money comes straight from the
pockets of north american taxpayers
indeed used to expand the war against
the people about saldivar
saying he had been
indicated that he had called an
important in his hand
knows that uh... i wouldn't do anything
he would never want to learn
politically he we're no longer esteemed
creators of the u_s_ government
we demand that they stop standing
and helicopters that dropped bombs on
our family members included in the
country
that they send as medicine food which is
what we need a help for those of us who
have barely surviving
meridian
right there in the
i don't even think what we think it will
not implement
lying about it during my captivity a
secret military facility how was
interrogated and tortured
and while there i realized that among
the interrogators there were north
american citadels of dayton the brothers
twenty nine of them income
not that i'm a mandate
baby imo
we as mothers tell you to tell your
government meteorites hampton out of the
salvadoran
but the n_f_l_ bundle up
albania and when i feel like i've been
bugging me born with
seldom does this information reach the
people of the united states either been
led to believe that it is a democratic
country
intended nothing is unusual and on that
but the truth is that everyday a murder
capture tortured and disappear the
people at the start of the intended for
confronting said don't go there
dot by taking
i can send money and go vietnam point
the government accuses us the groups of
people struggling for human rights
of the members of the f_m_l_n_
non-police ideas
the innovative committee and me
landon
located at one eighteen years old
the government claims that union members
had tied to the f_m_l_n_
now would like to see if nothing else
only the economic any eating he probably
season is playing well and and melanie
and his testimony he said
the eight people without going into
people at home the up by the end of
via an eminent working for walking
around
if that's
in particular field
so but i love photographs
but he's implications are for us market
danger because they can use those
excuses and pretext to take vengeful
measures against us
but that is why it's quicker construe
are terrorized
for excellent care
no than mexico
and being
our family
it there are
lindsey lindsey as well
so a lot
three hardcore workers from the human
rights commission have disappeared
several have been captured an
assassinated five co-workers have been
jailed in the muddy on a prison they've
captured members of our families
than normal
if they
not on that glove the bundy yes
credit and knowing it was shot to death
in october of nineteen eighty seven
while taking his children to school
in march of nineteen eighty eight
and i just sent a note was captured and
tortured
there's currently a warrant out for the
rest of roberto guatemala
reassign and other unionists captured
with him has never been found
marie's house was blown up while she was
not at home
they could only take it anymore
it is a power struggle and they will not
silence at face
camaclang we will continue to speak out
in our country and around the world
against what is happening here and you
have a world where is that about a week
and put it on time
when he returns that you know my they
came together
but to more will come out the next day
they don't accomplish anything by
killing members of the popular movement
in you just grows stronger for tomorrow